à deux jours de la grève nationale
contre la réforme des retraites ce jeudi
à 19 janvier ça se précise des
perturbations sont prévues dans les
transports les écoles ou encore dans les
raffineries bonsoir Régine raleche
rebonsoir avec vous donc on parle de ces
prévisions de ces perturbations à qui
s'annoncent à quoi doit-on s'attendre
alors vous l'avez dit plusieurs secteurs
seront touchés par le mouvance sociale
ce jeudi du côté des transports la
circulation pourrait être très perturbée
notamment en Île-de-France et syndicats
et de la RATP et de la SNCF ont appelé à
je cite une grève puissante dans les
Yvelines il faudra s'attendre également
à de fortes perturbations les lignes CN
et U seront fortement impactées on
estime entre 70% et 80% des conducteurs
en grève et selon Mathieu bol Réda le
secrétaire général de la CGT Chemino
Versailles moins d'un train sur 3
circule rage jeudi le plan de transport
sera disponible ce soir à 20h sur le
site du Transilien
et comme la annoncé Michael eliteau rose
sachet également que certains employés
de raffinerie se mettront en grève ce
qui a suscité la panique chez les
automobilistes dans plusieurs
départements et dont celui des Yvelines
ou 18% des stations services sont à
court de carburant en ce qui concerne
l'éducation à quoi faut-il s'attendre
que des fermetures d'écoles par exemple
sont prévues jeudi et la grève a déjà
commencé ce mardi 17 janvier pour les
écoles du 1er degré les syndicats de
l'éducation nationale se sont mobilisées
et revendiquent la revalorisation de
leur métier dans les Yvelines 82 écoles
primaires étaient fermées aujourd'hui et
en ce qui concerne la grève de jeudi sur
un panel de 300 écoles primaires déjà
63% d'entre elles ont déclaré leur
intention de se mettre en grève de leur
côté les professeurs des collèges et
lycées n'ont pas l'obligation de se
déclarer grévistes 48 heures avant le
jour de la grève mais la mobilisation
s'annonce aussi importante selon
Delphine Romani secrétaire
départementale du SNES
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à vous rendre
sur les différents sites internet de vos
communes pour vous renseigner sur les
situations locales un petit mot aussi
sur la grève dans le secteur hospitalier
ça s'annonce dur aussi le secteur de la
Santé prévoit lui aussi de se mobiliser
la CGT santé et action sociale à déposer
un préavis de grève pour la journée du
19 janvier le mouvement pourrait
toutefois avoir moins de répercussions
que dans d'autres secteurs puisque la
fonction publique hospitalière on le
rappelle est soumise à un service
minimum voilà donc pour ces informations
c'est prévisions à deux jours de cette
grève nationale contre la réforme des
retraites merci Régine ralech